what's going on guys
Mother's Day is just about upon us so we
have a very special episode my mom
Deborah Rudnick is here with us on
screen junkies so this is your second
time on the screen junkie show what did
we do the first time and the first time
we had a horrible movie the human human
centipede yes look look he's making but
now we're going to watch a movie
together that is sure to make a mother
and son uncomfortable Fifty Shades of
Grey
I don't think I don't think that's
appropriate now you're familiar with
Fifty Shades of Grey right to get into
the book I've neither seen it nor read
the book myself we're going into this
cold mom I think that speaks well of you
actually that you haven't read the book
are you ready to do this I'll try but I
might put my hand over your eyes or
something like yeah well without any
further ado Fifty Shades of Grey
you do you have any interests outside of
work enjoy various physical pursuits
that's a little foreshadowing mother
what do you think those physical
pursuits include is basketball oh yeah
pickup games I'm sure this movie is all
about he and Dakota Johnson start a
pickup league basketball team I would
like to know more about you
uh-huh she's she's piqued his interest
do you stock cable ties cable ties cable
ties uh what does the average person you
cable ties for maybe it's a big hobbyist
rope well maybe he likes to fly kites
good girl a lost art yeah this is me she
drunk-dialed mom yo drunk-dialing is I
think I've done that really years ago
years ago who did you drunk-dial no
boyfriend Oh mom if you were mine you
wouldn't be able to sit down for a week
oh no he would have spanked her I guess
getting drunk I want to thank you for
not spanking me as a child maybe you
need it Wow he looked in a really nice
building in Seattle okay yeah I wonder
if he knows Frazier it's just beyond
this door what is my playroom Oh what is
playroom intelligence is cave daddy's
playroom his mancave yeah he's got
football posters whoa exercise room um
you could call it that
- give her one of those outfits to wear
you know there yet a [ __ ] outfit mom you
know what a [ __ ] is somebody with a limp
oh yeah okay look gimpy leg sure gimpy
legs sure sure
oh oh okay uh oh
so uncomfortable you think he would have
given her a drink or something the other
section OOP an injection of what he's
about to give her an injection you
haven't seen that hot
you know I'm what do you mean I'm used
to these animalistic type things where
they jump animalistic type things and
movies are nothing Oh mom oh well you
know you did come into this world
somehow I would the stork brought me
well with a little help
ha ha ha from the dock the what the duck
I'd all right I'm lost his mother's
friends seduced him and he was her
submissive for six years how would you
feel if mrs. Newman seduced me what what
I mean poor mrs. Newman yes lucky mrs.
Newman I'm never gonna tell her I did
this ha ha ha find it I would like to
[ __ ] you into the middle of next week
well that's a fine how-do-you-do hmm I
want to take you to my playroom mine is
a start and flavored
oh she gets so drippy every time he
touches
three
he looks like he's one step from mingi
maniac good Christian oh just like when
they first met is that it
oh my mom give me your thoughts on Fifty
Shades of Grey what would you do if
Christian gray made you the same offer
not into bondage I never was mother
you it makes me very happy to hear you
say that I love you I'm so glad you're
here and just want to say happy Mother's
Day happy Mother's Day are you gonna do
something nice for your mom on Mother's
Day please don't watch a weird movie
with her but if you were what movie
would it be what would the weirdest
movie that you wouldn't want to watch
with your mom be let us know in the
comments below best answer we're gonna
send you one of our new screen junkies
t-shirts I want to thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick happy Mother's
Day
bye bye so how are they joined together
mom hey ma'am